Well,
when you delve into the literature on
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam and their
versions of the afterlife and heaven,
they're quite different in the Jews are
far less obsessed with going some place
after death.
In fact,
originally they had.
They were going no place at all.
Shell was just nothing.
It was just.
He returned to where you were before.
You're allowed just no place,
uh,
and so,
so that,
that religion is far more focused on the
here and now.
Like we have a moral duty to help
people,
the poor and so on now and to live
better lives and more lives of dignity
and honor and let now and at
Christianity really started off more
like that.
Then kind of morphed over the centuries
and it particularly in fundamentalist
and evangelicals in the 20th century
toward this place.
We're going to go right now.
Yeah.
You kind of had the schism in
Christianity today between the kind of
the,
the fundamentalists that are constantly
talking about the afterlife and
accepting Jesus and they're focused on
missionary,
working into birding people versus say
maybe the Rick Warren's of the world
that want to put their money into a soup
kitchens and helping the poor and,
and,
and Christians have a moral duty to help
those in need and not so much focused on
the next life.
And yeah,
it's funny because there,
there are real dangers associated with
both those kinds of conceptualizations
mean you alluded to one danger that was
associated with,
let's call those who are concerned more
with the immediate present.
And that's the starting to manifest
itself in these,
in these,
um,
technological immortalists.
They're saying,
well,
we should transform the nature of being
extraordinarily radically right here and
now so that we have heaven in
immortality here.
You think,
well,
what do we lose by doing that?
You know,
that's the question that's really worth
asking because if we're transhuman then
we lose being human.
And it may be that we actually don't
want to lose being human.
Even though being human means suffering
and malevolent,
something like that,
it's a very hard question,
but then the Christians,
this is what we need.
She went after the Christian.
Since it's such an ax.
He said,
well,
if you despise the current world and you
leave everything to be rectified in the
afterlife,
then you just abandoned life itself and
you're really trainers to life.
How,
how to steer through those to shoot two
shows,
let's say is thing or to cliff's.
That's a very difficult proposition.
Well,
it's the message.
My message in the book to,
to the military eons and the cryonics
and transhumanism and so on is I'm glad
you're working on this problem.
You know,
but because I say to Schermer don't you
want to live to be a thousand years and
my response is look,
just get me the 90 without cancer and
100 without Alzheimer's and 110 without
being plugged into machines and lying in
a.
because that's not alive.
And
so I'm glad people are working on like,
what's the best diet,
how much?
What can we do to improve our memory?
And so on.
That's all.
Great,
and I'm glad and I'm glad Kurzweil is
now the chief engineer of all Google.
I mean he's got some resources to do
something about this,
but that this focus on living a thousand
years,
your first one you may miss the little
incremental things we can do,
but also you're missing out now.
There's this fell in my right about,
in the book I'm on Ray Kurzweil.
It's a little kind of biographical film
of him,
a transcendent man and he's constantly
talking about,
you know,
living forever and so on and he's
obsessed with his father.
His father died when he was 51.
The father was 51 and,
and ray was kind of missed out having a
father figure because the father was
always working and ray was a,
you know,
a,
a real entrepreneur achiever from his
teenage years.
So he was always working and the film
kind of follows him around collecting
everything he can about his father and
he keeps it in the basement of his house
and he wants to resurrect his father and
a computer and it's like,
Whoa,
boy.
Freud would have a field day with this
Indian guy,
but there's something,
there's something going on there.
This sort of rose,
you know,
I see this,
this strange dichotomy and attitude that
you just described.
Even characterizing use that in my own
life because I'm very interested in
technologies that stave off aging,
dietary manipulations,
and I have this machine in my basement
that's intense pulse light,
late intense pulse light machine that's
unbelievable skin rejuvenator.
It's an absolute miracle.
This machine.
And it'll take,
it'll take sun damage from your skin
completely.
And forced rejuvenation.
It's like,
it's just like using photoshop on your
skin.
It's amazing.
And,
but,
um,
and so I think,
well,
isn't it interesting to do everything
possible to prolong youth in life?
But at the same time there's another
part of me that's thinking,
well,
this is something I wrote about it in
this new book that I'm publishing.
I'm just thinking about socrates and his
ability to accept his death.
No.
And what socrates seems to have revealed
in his acceptance of his death was that
if you live your life properly,
then you may be.
You lived your life in some sense,
you've exhausted it in some sense.
The question is if you,
if you lived a thousand years,
well,
what exactly,
what exactly would you do?
You know,
like I've had kids and I loved having
kids,
but I wouldn't have them again.
Like I wouldn't do that again,
I don't think.
And I have a grandchild and that's fine,
but that's a new thing.
Like I've had a career and I as I get
older,
the idea of having 10 more careers
seems.
It's not like I'm not interested in it,
but it doesn't grip me the same way that
it would have say 20 years ago.
And so I wonder like I wonder if it is
the case that life is in some sense
structured so that its finitude as
necessary and not something that should
be well casually transcended.
Let's say.